- Let me tell you what.
The future you need to be worried about
is not the next 20 years,
but the next 20 minutes.
What are you going to be doing?
What are you going to be
doing to be effective?
I mean, you'll never be perfect.
Good Lord, we're all human basket cases.
I mean, that's how we're all wired.
- He's the former co-CEO of Primerica.
He's a sought-after speaker,
motivator, and business author.
He currently serves on
the Board of Directors
for Primerica and LegalShield.
He's John Addison, and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules for Success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, if you hear something
that really resonates with
you, please leave it down
in the comments below, put
quotes around it, as well
so other people can be inspired.
Also, when you write it down,
you're much more likely to lock
it in for yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
- Your habits determine
what direction you're going.
Your success in life,
your results in life,
are in direct proportion to your habits.
Not what you say you're going to do,
but what are you going to do.
You've got to develop successful habits.
And I believe that starts
with being a daily goal setter
and a daily goal hitter.
Too many people spend their whole life,
they say they're dreaming,
but they're really just pipe dreams.
They're thinking about what they
want to be doing in 20 years
and what their plans are
way out in the future.
Let me tell you what, the
future you need to be worried
about is not the next 20
years but the next 20 minutes.
What are you going to be doing?
What are you going to be
doing to be effective?
When you get up every
day, know your priorities.
Life will overwhelm you.
Stuff will overwhelm you.
With all the information we have now,
whether it's your phone,
or sometimes I think we have
smart phones and stupid people.
I mean, it is so easy to get
consumed by a bunch of stuff
that is not going to get you
where you want to get to.
Say every day, "I will do
today what others don't,
"so I will have tomorrow
what others won't."
You've got to choose to be effective.
Know what your priorities are.
Know what your must do's are.
Don't let your phone, don't let
your, you know, your tablet,
don't let the TV, don't let your friends
knock you off what are
the most important things
to get done today.
Sir Winston Churchill
didn't have an inbox,
he had an Action This Day box.
And so things didn't get into that box
that he wasn't going
to deal with that day.
So as John Wooten said, "Make
today your masterpiece."
Get up today and get it done.
Finish the day, attack the day,
and go change your life.
You know, I believe with
everything in me it honestly is
your ability to drive
yourself and your team
to a level of excellence
that is what's going to
determine your future.
I was watching the other
day, right after we got back
from the RVP meetings, and
I was sitting in my study
and there was on HBO a
special about Vince Lombardi
that's been on a number of times.
And you know, in that it was Bart Starr
talking about the first,
you got to remember,
this was a guy that had
been locked out of jobs,
locked out of jobs.
I mean, he was like in his late 40s
by the time he got his
first head coaching job.
And you know, it was in Green Bay, okay.
I mean, it was like in the middle of,
it was like my God it wasn't
with the New York Giants,
it was in Green Bay, and
they'd been terrible.
In his first meeting with the team,
Bart Starr said he always remembered
the exact words he said.
He said, "We will relentlessly
pursue perfection.
"We won't catch it, but in our quest,
"we will catch excellence."
And see, in life I believe
that's what separates
the people that go do something great
is that they relentlessly
pursue perfection.
They beat themselves up every
day when they're not perfect.
When they don't do the
right thing and stuff.
But by being relentless at that,
I mean, you'll never be perfect.
Good Lord, we're all human basket cases.
I mean, that's how we're all wired.
I mean, we all got more
snakes in the attic than,
I mean trust me, I know I do.
But at the end of the
day, when you relentlessly
pursue perfection,
you'll catch excellence.
The one thing that is absolutely certain
is change happens.
Things change.
Look, you can either embrace change
or you can get run over by change.
You can either shape change,
or stand there screaming,
kicking, and complaining
about things changing.
The world changes.
Time moves on.
And you have to adapt and be a person,
you know, like I said,
you can either (chuckles)
you can either be a force for change,
or you can be a victim of change.
You've got to embrace
change and get after it.
You know, everybody wants
to change the world.
But nobody wants to change themselves.
And you've got to look
at yourself every day
and say, "Am I adpating?
"Am I moving forward?
"Am I a part of the future
or am I just sitting
"and telling stories about the past?"
Look, the world will be,
I don't know what the world's
going to look like in 10 years.
I wish I did.
I'd make some investments
and make a lot of money.
But the reality is I
know one thing for sure,
it'll look different than it does today.
So every day, work on
yourself, get better.
You're a human becoming,
not a human being.
Work on yourself, get better,
and go be a force for change,
not a victim of change.
Let me tell you, I'm
going to tell you a key.
It's not easy to win.
If it sounds easy, it's sleazy.
In life, you got to pay a price.
You got to fight.
Every day, you got to get
up and make a decision
that you're going to
play wide open, all out,
leave it all on the field.
Every day is a battle.
You know, Napoleon Hill said,
"If think could grow rich,
"thoughts are things."
Earl Nightingale in The
Strangest Secrets said,
"You become what you think."
That is the truth.
That's the why life is.
So my question for you is
who controls your thoughts?
Who controls your thinking?
Who do you give the keys to your brain to?
Turn on the news.
We have mastered, you know,
technology and information
is great, but I believe
with every great thing,
there's an equal bad thing to it.
Now you can put garbage
into your brain 24/7.
You turn on the news,
there's a person talking,
telling you bad crap.
Bad crap's going across the bottom.
Bad crap scrolls down the sides.
(audience cheering)
Now I'm not saying don't watch the news
and just be an ignoramus, or anything.
But what I'm telling to you
is you've got to be careful
what you allow to get here.
You know, in data
processing there's a saying,
garbage in, garbage out.
With the brain, it's
garbage in, garbage stays.
You got to be careful.
You know, I'm a huge gardener.
I love to garden.
My wife and I have a home in
North Georgia, got 50 acres.
When I get home next week,
you know, I'm planting
all my tomatoes and all this stuff.
I have a huge, huge garden.
I love to garden.
But one of the things
you learn about gardening
is it is easier to grow weeds
than it is to grow vegetables.
Weeds just show up.
It's amazing.
And it's very much like the brain.
You've got a life.
If you want to grow positive
things in your life,
you got to weed your brain all the time.
And if you let a weed,
you need to weed early and often.
If you let it get tall,
you know, pull the weed out
and the root'll snap off
and then it's right back.
With your brain, it's the same way.
You have to fight to be positive.
That's what you read, who you talk to,
who you hang out with.
See in life, there's a
power of association.
But I tell you an important
thing many of you need to learn
is the power of disassociation.
Every one of you has people in your life
that if you ask them how they're doing,
you wish you could stuff the
words back in your mouth,
because they will tell you.
Negative people share much more frequently
than positive people.
They will spend two hours
just putting their garbage,
and they just crush you down.
You got to be around positive
people, positive thinking,
positive things in your brain.
But that's not a bunch
of rah-rah-rah hype.
That is a fact.
You're in the people attraction business.
And so I tell people all the time,
"John, give me a key, what can I do?"
Smile!
Walk fast.
Be going somewhere.
I live in airports.
I'm a three million miler on Delta.
I live in an airport.
And I am amazed at the number of people
that come up to me and go, "John!"
They don't know my name, they'll just go,
"You seem so happy, something
good must've happened."
Yeah, I woke up.
Most of us that come from
just normal backgrounds,
we don't see ourselves
doing abnormal things.
The world is full people,
who were born on third
and think they hit a triple,
and they got all this
confidence, all this stuff.
For most of us, it's not that way.
We don't think we're wired or programmed
to do something great.
Well I'm telling you, that thought
is nothing but a fear,
nothing but a doubt.
It's what holds you in place.
You got to work hard on understanding
you have within you the power to change,
the power to do something great.
And those fears are going to crop up,
particularly in the middle
of the night when you wake up
and you're scared to
death about what to do.
They're going to crop up and
they're going to hold you in place.
Quite often if you're
trying something different,
they crop up in the middle of your dreams.
When you're asleep at night,
those fears and doubts creep in.
Understand they're not real.
They are things in your head
that have been programmed
into you by your past life.
Wrestle with those fears.
You'll never conquer
them, but control them.
And go out and live the life you deserve.
Choose to win, control your
thinking, and go win big.
I did not want to go to college,
but with my mom it was not an option.
I was going to college.
But I wanted to quit.
I was looking for a reason to quit.
And so the first class, I'm
sitting there, Dr. Miller,
Political Science 101, and
get there the first day.
Now where do you, if you
really don't think you belong,
where do you sit?
Back row, far back as you can get,
I was almost out the door,
sitting in the back of the room.
And at the end of the,
you got to understand, I
was from the country, okay?
You get to UGA then and most
of the students in your class
came from Buckhead, which is
the very nice area of Atlanta,
and went to the right schools,
and they had all this college prep stuff,
and I didn't have any of that.
And so, this is in the '70s
when the preppy look was in,
the girls with the big bouffy hair
and bows in it and everything.
And so this girl with
this big bouffy hair,
a bow in it and stuff was
sitting in front of me.
And at the end of class she goes,
"Dr. Miller, will we
receive a syllabus today?"
And I'm like, hell I had no
idea what a syllabus was.
If she'd have said "A schedule
when we're taking the test,"
I'd have gone, "Yeah,
I need one of those."
So I leave class and go back
to my dorm, Milledge Hall,
and go down the end to the pay phone,
you know, no cell phones and stuff then,
and I call my dad and I go,
"Dad, I hate this place.
"I hate these people, I
hate everything about it.
"I hate it, hate it, hate it.
"I want to come home."
And he said, "Son, we've
already paid your tuition
"for this quarter.
"Just go through Christmas
and then come home
"and we'll talk about it."
And so I went, "Okay,
Dad, that's fair enough."
So we go back.
A few weeks later we have our first exam.
Now, don't let the accent
throw you, I'm pretty good
in school, and I was
always good in school.
That's why Mom made me go to,
and if I had like a history class,
political science class,
if I read something,
I remember things.
And so, first exam, I get my
test back and I made a 98.
And I looked down in front of me,
and that little smart butt girl
that knew what a syllabus was made a 46.
I bet she didn't wind
up CEO of a multibillion
financial services company.
But now,
but the reason I tell the
story is what if my dad
had said, "Son, get your butt home,
"I'm sick of hearing from you."
And I went back to Mobile Chemical Company
and was the funny guy
working on the assembly line.
Where would my life have gone?
What would, I wouldn't be
speaking in front of a big group.
I wouldn't be wealthy.
None of those things
would've happened in my life,
if I'd have let her make me quit.
See that's life.
It moves on small decisions.
When you keep going
when your friend quits.
When you keep moving.
Here's reality.
New people, I'm going
to tell you the reality.
Your friends don't want you to succeed.
They want to tell you that
you're doing some crazy crap
that you'll get over.
If you succeed, you put pressure on them.
If you win, it makes them uncomfortable.
They want to be able to
say, "Told ya so." (guffaws)
You've got to make a decision
that you're going to prove
all the doubters wrong.
That you're going to stay tough.
Key forward.
I know now I'm reaching an age,
I just turned 59 the other day
and I'm reaching an age where
you do look back on things
a little bit.
And you know, as I look
at the world today,
I'm going to be completely
honest with you.
Sometimes I'm afraid we're
losing our toughness.
The ability to demand results.
I believe there are two
things in business, in sports,
or whatever it is, there's
results and there's bull.
I mean, most people spend all
their time making excuses,
talking about why they didn't get it done.
Winners get results.
There is a scoreboard in life.
There is a thing called making it happen.
I've been at business points in my career,
you know in 2008 when
the economy collapsed,
my partner Williams and I knew
we had to get our business
separated from Citigroup.
We knew we had to make it happen.
Not getting it done was not an option.
We had to make it happen.
And it was hard and we didn't
know what to do every day.
But when a door would
close, we'd find a window.
You've got to win.
You got to take responsibility
for where you're at.
Sometimes even if it's not your fault.
And then you got to go get after.
When you play in golf, I
used to play golf a lot,
you hit the ball off
the tee into the rough,
you can't just go, "You know,
I meant it to be out there
"in the middle of the fairway."
You got to play the ball where it lies
and go get results.
So that requires toughness.
It requires discipline.
And it requires getting
after it on a daily basis.
So that's my challenge to you.
Whatever challenge or
problem or where you're at
in your career, go out,
get tough, and get results.
Weathervanes typically are politicians,
where whatever way the winds blowing,
whatever the mood of the moment is,
whatever the polls say,
they spin that direction.
Leaders are lighthouses.
There's a consistency to them,
there's a strength to them.
You know, lighthouses are only needed
when the weather's stormy.
When it's beautiful, they're
just a beautiful building.
But when the seas are stormy
and it's dark and rainy
and foggy, that's when
you need a lighthouse.
A leader has to be a rock,
someone of consistency,
that when the storms,
whether it's a business
or the economy, whatever's
happening to the organization
that you're over, that
you're a human Alka Seltzer,
you calm the organization.
I've worked for people that
were quote-unquote leaders
who would bring a bucket of gas to a fire
and make it just turn into a blaze
by how they reacted to it.
Great leaders are calmers.
Great leaders are people
that when maybe everything
is hectic and chaotic,
but when people see them,
hear from them, they're calmer.
I believe a peaceful mind generates power.
- Thank you guys so much for watching
I made this video because
Pablo Bernal asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it
down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what did you love most
about this video?
Which clip resonated the most with you,
and what lesson are you
going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or your business?
Please leave it down in the comments below
and I'm super curious to figure it out.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout out to Joesph DeVito.
Joseph, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word.
I really, really, really appreciate it,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever Your One Word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
- You've got to take control of your life.
Not waiting for the government.
Not waiting for a corporation.
You taking charge of your economy.
You know, a lot of people
call it the gig economy,
the share economy, all
of those kind of things.
What I really think it is
is you controlling the means
to your income, instead
of letting the means
to your income control you.
It's you taking control of your life.
It's you becoming the captain of your ship
and charting your course and
deciding when you want to work,
how you want to work.
But see, that takes education.
That takes working on yourself.
The key to you is you.
And that means you've got to improve.
You've got to learn,
you've got to get better.
You've got to hone your skills
and your craft every day.
And that's where I
believe success comes in.
A lot of people adapt
to pressure differently.
You know, Peyton Manning,
who just retired,
I heard him speak one time
and a great quote he had was,
"Pressure is a privilege."
I mean, you know, I'm sure
he's going to miss it now.
Pressure is a privilege.
Lighten up, enjoy it, enjoy the journey.
It goes by very fast.
- What you focus on grows.
What you focus on grows.
If you focus on problems,
problems will multiply.
If you focus on opportunities,
opportunities will multiply.
You have to choose what you're
going to spend your time on.
See every day, you're either
getting better or worse.
You don't stay the same in life.
People don't stay the same.
They're either getting
better or they're worse.
You're not a human being,
you're a human becoming.
Every day, you are changing your life.
And you are every day
becoming your current
most dominant thought.
Not what you say you're thinking about,
not what you tell other
people you're doing.
You are becoming what you're thinking.
Napoleon Hill said, "Thoughts are things."
Thoughts aren't random
electro, you know, synapses
between nerve endings.
Thoughts are things.
What are you wanting to be in your brain?
What are you focusing on?
What are you spending your time on?
Who influences you?